hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
very thrilled and excited for you to
listen to this episode with comedian
actor
uh
new chicken owner matt walsh oh you
might know him from veep or from years
decades of improv comedy or from the
billion other uh hilarious comedic films
that he is a part of um
i loved talking to him about his foyer
into comedy we talk about psychology we
talk about digital media obsession he's
got a new movie called unplugging out uh
co-starring eva longoria where the the
couple takes a digital detox we talk all
about that also if you are obsessed with
beep
they have a podcast he and his co-star
uh timothy simmons called second in
command where they are re-watching
episodes of veep and uh recognizing uh
the complexity and the whole world of it
that they might have not seen while they
were making it so
uh i enjoyed this conversation
thoroughly i had a beautiful time i
might have gotten a little obsessed
with the fact that he owns chickens but
that's on me
otherwise i hope you enjoyed this
episode as much as i did uh matt wolfe
on not 2d
[Music]
okay matt i have so many things to ask
you about and talk to you about first
thing on this beautiful rainy day in los
angeles i'm curious wha what's your
first thing you do in the morning when
you wake up do you have a routine do you
have rituals do you wake up with a
certain
zest to your day or is it different
every day
lately i've been uh
i started during the pandemic raising
chickens so my routine in the morning is
to
get up maybe make a cup of coffee and
then
grab some scraps for the chicken
uh chicken groups and then go outside
with the dog and uh
open up the chicken coop and throw some
feet out and make sure they got water
and so
what was the impetus to get chickens was
it just the pandemic or this been
something you had been thinking about in
the background for a while
um i think the pandemic made it made me
think about it because
i don't know it was like a hobby thing
like i i baked sourdough during the
pandemic somebody gave me like a
sourdough starter so nice i think
everyone reverted back to like basics
and
also in the weird world where like
grocery shelves were empty and you
couldn't find things it was like i don't
know how it popped into my universe but
i thought i have friends who've raised
chickens and i like we have room we have
like a decent sized yard so yeah i just
thought about the idea so i built a
chicken coop whoa uh it wasn't great it
was like a shanty
uh
a humble coop yeah and my wife wasn't
super excited about it so then we bought
a nicer version of a coupe which is now
what they live in
is there a learning curve on
housing and raising chickens
yeah i think it's keeping it
tidy rats love chicken so you got to
keep everything tidy and uh
cleaning up after them getting some hay
uh
i think keeping them
alive you know we lost a few over the
years
when they're little the dogs
our dog went after some of the little
chicks so that wasn't great
so learning learning how to protect them
when they're little little
um and then just the routine of it all
yeah they threat seemingly like have
found a home here and
keep an eye on them and there's no like
predators our yard's pretty like walled
off so there's no like coyotes or cats
or dogs that that roam in so
it's not too hard it's a fair amount of
work
yeah but in general and then you get to
use the you clean up the hay and you can
use that for compost on your trees so
it's kind of like a little farm wow yeah
biggest little farm a real return to
nature a little bit
very cool i love that you're saying this
with like a peloton behind you
well that was my wife's idea which i
said sure and i've only used it three
times in the last year and a half i have
never used one what's the experience
like it's good it is a good workout like
i
i wish i did it more
okay but uh it's good it's like a
20 minute 30 minute 40 minute workout
depending on what you you select i've
never done like a live class it's always
like a video right right um yeah it
seems a bit overwhelming but probably
ultimately very rewarding yeah it is
like any workout if you just show up you
always feel better at the end of it but
i've only done it three times so
my wife is a little more uh regular
that's great um okay i kind of want to
go back to the beginning i i'm so
curious about your whole kind of journey
into the world of entertainment
creativity comedy how did this start for
you
i like your backdrop on the wall by the
way is that a painting what is that it's
a mural done by these two comedian
artists called very gay paint and it's a
very gay mural they call it the gay eye
of sauron um which i
am a huge fan of i told them that my
aesthetic was sophisticated nickelodeon
set and i think they truly delivered for
me i do i like the color and the pattern
really nice thank you i appreciate that
uh so my creative journey
um
how did it start exactly yeah how did
you find i mean did you find comedy
first was there something like a seed
planted when you were younger was there
some point in your life that you
realized that like this is the outlet
for you that the arts were the world
that you needed to be in or belonged in
in some capacity
yeah i think my
interest in comedy was always there i
always was
good at remembering jokes and
uh
could like recite jokes once i'd heard
them and i liked the
structure of them perhaps as a little
kid
and then i think as i got older i
realized
uh certainly the power of like making
people laugh was attractive to me like
in a big family seeing my parents laugh
at movies or my dad
yeah would always tell stories and so
because you're one of what seven
children that's wild yeah so i think
like
comedy was just something that i always
liked i didn't know
that there were careers in comedy
necessarily but i did always like it and
then
i did a
variety show my senior year in high
school with some friends where you make
fun of the teachers and we got to write
sketches nice rehearsed them and there
was a woman in the theater department
who ran the show and she was very like
you're actually good at this you should
think about this and that was like the
first time
i felt like reinforced because i was
always like class clown and could be
counted on for being sort of
disruptive or it was a way for me to get
my attention and my identity out sure in
various settings and sometimes to my
detriment like i was not a great student
in high school because i was
doing a lot of attention seeking pranks
and mischief
etc so but the variety show was really
the first formalized like
performance rehearsal
and then writing and creating something
and then using it in front of an
audience or delivering in front of
audience and then seeing it succeed was
really
powerful and then of course the
adoration you get in the hallways after
those shows is pretty unique as well so
i think that was the beginning seat and
then in college i didn't
really pursue it for various reasons i
think
probably
didn't have the courage to go full
into it or didn't know what was on the
other side of it but ultimately
at the end of college i started taking
improv classes i took one acting class
in college and
that was like one of my only i was like
a business major then a
liberal arts then a psych major
so i wanted to be i wanted to be a
psychologist so right after college yeah
so i wanted to get a job in
psychology so i worked on a psych floor
right out of college then at night i was
doing sketch with these guys that i met
in my improv class in chicago yeah and
then at some point
i realized that i had to just do one of
them and uh
comedy was the stakes were much lower
like psychology's pretty heavy duty so
but they do feel like they
i'm also fascinated by psychology i i
know i can't ever be a therapist i think
that that's too far-reaching for me but
i do think that therapists are kind of
like superheroes and i do think those
are really complementary avenues to
study like the human condition
and that filters and fuels kind of an
ability to find comedy in it
yeah i think listening is is a big part
of a good therapist in recognizing the
patterns of you know destructive
behavior uh i don't know people always
say like they always assume like oh
psychology is a great companion for my
comedy i don't know that i
consciously draw on it but i guess any
background or any specialization that
gives you a foundation of
information and approach to
something is interesting
i actually did a research paper my
senior year which
with like rats and things like that wow
and then yeah
and then there was another one about
perfection you know the game perfection
where you have
uh those little cubes that are like a
triangle and circle elsewhere yeah so
it's like a time trial and i took like
50 college students from the psych
department and i tried to see
who learned to learn better and what in
my little study women were better at
learning to learn in other words their
successive trials
they got better better better they they
found organizational systems inside this
little trial like if i gave everybody
three if i if i gave everyone three
trials
you would see a more increased shaving
of time
from the female like subjects as opposed
to the men
interesting that was like one of the
things that i took away from that but
that
yeah it was interesting
yeah do you ever
or would you ever consider going back
into psychology
in any capacity
i guess i would if it was like
someone said we need a therapist and
i'll set up all the classes for you and
you can you just have to show up
just start showing up and i'll i'll walk
like i would need like an advisor
and a mentor
and someone to like teach me what
classes i needed to take like
pursuing it on my own i just don't have
the drive yeah yeah yeah but i do i am
fascinated by a friend of mine is going
through his
psych degree and
i took some grad school classes in it
but i i'm always asking you like what
are you studying i do find it
interesting yeah
well okay so that's been in the
background but then comedy and the arts
stuck for you it was that
taking improv classes and then just kind
of like feeling the bug feeling the sort
of addictive quality of it for yourself
yeah i think it is
one is like that hit that a crackhead or
a heroin addict has where you where
you're in a class and you i remember the
moment i was doing like an improvised
scene with someone
in a level two at a place called players
workshop and
we were able to sustain a comedic
scene for like three minutes and have
the classes engaged and laughing and it
was
going on stage without any concept of
what the scene was about and then
sustaining that
and then getting you know that
reinforcement
uh
was amazing yeah and so that was like
something i was chasing for a long time
that improv
comedy sketch sort of uh it was amazing
to me yeah it is truly
um
there's a sense of like
magic powers almost of this like control
of this able this like godlike creation
that i've made something from absolutely
nothing and it is providing a service to
people in some capacity
um yeah and it's like a magic trick like
you know without an audience it probably
wouldn't be as amazing yeah you know
that's very true
because laughter
justifies why you're doing it like
hearing the laughter but
it is that i agree it is it is sort of a
miraculous
god-like quality you can conjure up with
someone who's equally
interested and trained and supportive
yeah i mean so you've
founded improv theaters you've worked in
this capacity for so long was there a
point
in which you had to
limit the amount of performance and
involvement that you were doing in that
world
well
was it always kind of consistently like
this is part of my
creative dna in some capacity
i think for a long time it was i think
there was sort of like a pickup
mentality to doing like a once a week
show or a couple times a month
just to get your uh to get some laughs
and stay sharp and
it does keep the creative juices flowing
so i did like being able to drop into a
regular comedic show once a week but as
i've sort of gotten out of that habit
really since the pandemic came
i don't know that i miss it like i do
miss it but i don't know that i'll
structure my life in a way
where i'll have that once a week show
again because there's part of me that
knows that you sort of age out of improv
like i do think it is a young person's
game
uh certainly the audience is there's a
generational gap which
i always talk to the audience even the
other performers like there was a time
when we were all sort of the same age
now yeah i feel like i'm always the
oldest person on stage which is great
but it's a perspective it is a
perspective sure but it's also like
cultural references like comedy
is
steeped in like cultural references and
concerns
of younger people and so it's okay like
and i also enjoy
being home with my family on a sunday
night as opposed to getting in the car
and going down you know
you have chickens that need you now
my
my human chickens and then my chicken
chickens need me as well as our two dogs
yeah well it's interesting that you
you think of it as a young person's kind
of um playground a little bit because it
does i guess i've never thought about
that capacity before and it does seem
very true that it does rely on being
kind of tapped into some cultural pulse
that i think is much more accessible
when you're
younger and that's your only concern is
understanding what's happening in the
world in real time constantly and i do
think yeah life starts to create avenues
that you actually need to care about and
uh you know little things that you need
to keep alive outside of the comedy
world i'm curious when you
moved a little bit away from that and we
get into this like veep category now and
you're you're doing more of a
still playful and comedic world but more
structured
was there
any uh
like how was that experience for you
going into a show like that and then it
taking off in such a capacity and having
such an impact culturally
and i know that you have a podcast now
where you're re-watching all of it so
i'm curious
if now going back and watching it is
something you wanted to do
and uh
second to that what the experience of
looking back on it is for you
well
it's funny the the v podcast came up
during the pandemic because it was like
something
we could do during the pandemic but it
took so long to like get it in motion
and so
uh so that's where that impetus came
from and tim and i have been friends for
a long time so we enjoy like you know
goofing around or
doing bits or
etc so it's been fun to do
um but being on a show like beep is
is it is a remarkable ride there's no
i've been on many shows that i think are
quality comedy but they don't
necessarily get the reception or the
exposure or the support
or the cultural like significance or
praise if you will
and veep is one of those rare shows that
it was an amazing cast stupendous
writing and also the attention you know
of the culture was was concerned about
what we were doing yeah and engaged with
it so that is a rare ride indeed so that
was magnificent like you just don't know
uh if you're ever going to land in
something like that
and uh and doing the podcast where i go
back and re-watch
veep what i'm learning is is that
when you're an actor inside a show
you're so myopic about your lines and
your scene
even then when you watch it like of
course i watched every i'm not a fan of
watching myself too much i'm like all
right that's enough yeah that was going
to be my other question i have a very
difficult time there's a difference i
think between like nostalgia the idea of
it versus actually
looking at it
like confronting yourself with yourself
yeah like if you went back and watched
some of your episodes this show
right and i don't know exactly i've been
trying to figure out why and i it's so
interesting to hear that you have that
instinct too and i'm curious like
if you know why
that comes up for you
well i think there's like vanity like we
focus on like oh my god i look old and
there's also like
as an actor an artist you're like oh i
could improve that or that's not the
best take yeah or like uh could have
done that better or that and then
there's also like just
ego in general like you're like looking
at the show and hoping you come off well
so there's all these like insecurities
or
human qualities that i think interfere
with an objective viewing
of anything which is normal like it's
not like uh it's not a flaw it's just
how people are yeah so having some years
behind it now
and going back into veep i totally
appreciate the show like a fan like i'm
not so engaged about like oh my god i
look fat or like oh i could have done
that better like jeez i
i wish i would have like you know
whatever there's no like regret or like
kind of defense mechanism being
triggered i just watch it as a fan and i
can let go of a lot of that stuff and so
that's been a real joy and like the
realization of like all the wonderful
things that are
in that show like it's true appreciation
as a fan
and it's just an interesting
sort of uh
experiment really to go through
something like that and and to be
able to like enjoy it and then talk
about it and also discover memories
around it from other people that we
bring on the show you're like oh my god
i forgot that or like we did shoot that
scene and they never used it like it's
just like
that's the nostalgia part of it it
brings you back to a certain time and
place and it's also
a memory
sharpener because we're not trusted
narrators like ultimately we're not
build
we're not built as human beings to like
retell events
that uh happened years ago because we we
have the way they're encoded
uh isn't precise and also like there's
emotional things that need to trigger
them or sometimes we hide them because
they are emotional so ultimately you
realize like when you sit across from
somebody who's in the same episode
and on the same show and you listen to
their experience and it's like oh yeah
that was that was it that's kind of how
i watched the show it's like
coming at me it's like technicolor now
and it's like so beautiful and wonderful
it's like all these things i couldn't
realize because i was like an actor
memorizing my lines and like
trying to get it right and like seeing
the story through that character's eyes
but once you can relax and just watch it
it's
great like it's a wonderful show that's
very cool yeah that you get the freedom
to zoom out and like appreciate all the
things that you couldn't see in the
moment
very cool yeah
um okay we're gonna take a quick break
when we get back i'm so interested in um
your new feature unplugging uh as it
relates to all social media stuff so
we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast uh if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you and uh second thing if you are
enjoying yourself here in this not too
deep world we've built and you'd like to
leave us a review that would be so
wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little review comment how are you
feeling good bad otherwise maybe just
good or otherwise would be appreciated
other than that enjoy the podcast
you've really taken to the chickens i'm
fascinated that's your favorite part of
my life it is i think
a very
interesting
detail of your life i think it's very
fascinating because to me i have no
experience with chickens but they seem
you know they require a certain level of
attention and delicacy and like
gentleness and concern that uh for
having kids and a dog to add chickens to
it i'm just like fascinated
well one it is
an experiment that i was able to fold my
kids into my daughter has continued to
sort of help me with them and two i
think it is like in a world going crazy
where nobody's in control and we're like
i don't know how long this is gonna last
yeah i don't know what's going on with
the world you feel like well at the very
least i can grow eggs
and my family will have it you know what
i mean it gives you some sort of an
agency totally the way that like we
might grow herbs in our garden or like
make sourdough like all these things or
start knitting well at the very least
we'll have clothing you know
i think there is a huge sense of
independence there that like you can
survive in a certain situation that i
don't have for myself so that's why i'm
like
fascinated by it that i'm like i know i
could probably run away if i needed to
but i couldn't get eggs for myself
readily available you didn't pick up a
uh
hobby or anything during the pandemic
nothing i tried to knit a little bit i
thought about the bread scenario very
often i got way more into watching
reality television as a survival
mechanism
um so that's
if anyone needs commentary on the real
housewives i will live forever if that
is my life force
that's funny um i'm curious to with the
with your children do they have an
understanding of what you do do they
fully
understand or appreciate it i think
sometimes yeah they do they've seen a
couple things i've done
you know uh tv or movies they don't
watch peep it's a little they could the
older ones could watch beef now but i
don't think they're very interested in
it yet
which is perfectly fine and i think it's
it's occasionally marked by like
people saying you know
if we're out to dinner like oh my god
can i get a picture like so they've seen
recognition of
my fame or my public life
in addition to their friends
watching a movie or tv show and telling
them oh my god i saw your dad on tv so
they i think they appreciate what i do
and they have certainly been to the
theater with me to you know to see shows
and we're doing
we do like a month or a holiday show
every year which we're going to try to
do again
so they've sort of been part of the
theater family do they have interest in
the arts and if they start to cultivate
that is that something that
is exciting for you concerns you
um i guess it concerns me both my wife
and i are actors so we know how
hard it can be to be rejected and tired
you know when you're when you're an
actor and you're getting rejection it's
sort of
overly
uh uh powerful perhaps because it's who
you are so they're it's not like you're
doing an accounting thing and you're
handing it to someone and they're like i
don't like these numbers do it again
it's like yeah your math is wrong yeah i
don't like who you are this whole thing
you're bringing
this thing
you've worked on every second that
you're awake every day no this whole
gestalt you're bringing into the room
not a fan
so
learning to separate yourself from that
is something you can do when you get
older but when you're younger so that's
the concern part of it is making sure
but our middle
our middle guy is very funny and
talented and he's they've expressed
interest in
you know voice over and things like that
so we'll see where it goes like if what
i would love if any of your listeners if
they know like a good theater in the
valley that's looking for kids to
audition
for a play i'd love to get them into
a play first so they can see because i
like the team sport aspect of theater
where you have to people rely on you
and like i don't want it to necessarily
go right to like getting an agent and a
manager and getting a
voiceover on a cartoon i want to i want
to like the whole experience yeah seeing
all the pieces of it and there's
uh it fosters community too that you
really feel like you're part of the
system that has to work together yeah
very exactly right exactly right um
speaking of systems let's talk about
unplugging
this um
film
is basically
you and your wife uh go away to do a
digital detox correct
how did this project come up uh
how did this happen
a buddy of mine brad morris and i just
wrote the concept of like
it started with like the concept of like
a soft apocalypse it's almost like
everything doesn't go to [ __ ] but like
you can't get wi-fi and your phone work
yes
and so from that
we just wrote a story about a
couple who because we all are addicted
to screams whether we admit it or not oh
hugely yeah yeah and so it's a it's a
marriage or a relationship where there's
some issues that they're not dealing
with
and
it's a symptom the fact that they're
both sort of so addicted even their
daughter to screens is a symptom of like
we need to like unplug and investigate
who we are when we're not around these
things so they go to a remote location
where there's no wi-fi no signal
and because they're so addictive they
don't know what to do with themselves at
first and then at some point
they get freaked out that the whole
world's ending and that the chinese
impact the electrical grid and so they
go off into the woods
so
but on that journey in general they
are able to unpack a couple of things
that they weren't dealing with in their
marriage
let's see i guess their secrets in a
classic theatrical sense like
this really bugged me and this was
terrible and i don't know where you are
and you know
those kind of moments
it's very interesting to me because it
feels obviously hyper relevant right now
i think especially
uh in the pandemic of it all our only
reliance has been on this form of
communication this form of connection
this form of
distraction whatever it might be
i'm curious like um
what your
personal relationship is with like
social media and
uh you know internet all that kind of
jazz
i'm a bit of a dinosaur quite honestly
like i really am like
social media
is all outgoing yeah mostly like i
promote things that i like or friends
things i'll promote those things uh
social causes i'll throw things out into
the universe projects i'm involved that
are raising money for cause so it's all
outward going but i don't scroll to see
what people are up to every day i don't
at all and i often time have my
assistant like can you post this for me
because i just i don't know how to do a
story i don't know how to do an
instagram story like
i don't know how to do half of it and
then
the other side of it is our kids like
you know tick tock and
trying to police that and it's all fine
like it's not inherently evil but
it is time-wasting in a way that like
for a young mind that's developing we're
constantly like trying to
set boundaries and keep them off of like
social media where like you know adult
things happen it's like just go slower
just just preserve a little innocence
you don't need to be exposed to the
whole world when you're 12 or 14 or feel
the pressure to have followers at that
age so i think we're doing an okay job
but ultimately like i'm sure our kids
spend way too much time on screens i
mean it's uh
it's so difficult like a half of well
the majority of my adolescence was
without the internet and the internet
was created in that like
moment and so
how do we even compare
being born into a world where the
internet is immediately available versus
not like there's no blueprint on
i'm fascinated by the psychology of like
kids raised with internet uh as adults
what's gonna happen with the byproduct
of all of that because it is
uh
it's a difficult thing to process like
you said having the entire world in your
hand available to you at any moment of
the day
yeah
it's exactly right and you
your general concern is just to preserve
a little innocence or just to go a
little slower
and i didn't get a phone i was like 31 i
think like the the cell phone yeah
entered my life at the age of 31 so
that's the generation i am yeah you know
and
these kids
by the same token i took great pride in
their ability to like navigate
technology because it's not going away
like right my son at the age of five was
like playing some game where he could
like
tom cruise in minority report like
stroke
key play turn
click like his dexterity i'm like oh
he'll survive in the future world you
know like part of me does take pride
that they are understanding technology
and they know how to use it but a lot of
those things
they develop quickly like you don't need
to spend a hundred hours to get that you
can spend five hours and get that you
know like after a while it's just
repetitive like tick-tock funny like
like after a while you're not really
building a
skill set yeah well is that kind of the
takeaway that you want audiences to have
with unplugging like is there kind of
that sort of messaging of like the over
reliance on it
way to keep me on task
very sweet that's my only interest this
is unplugging no this is about
unplugging the movie creating a
framework
yes
it's a wonderful comedy ultimately it's
a comedy right it's truly a comedy about
like how addictive we are to screens how
they can be an impediment to a marriage
how like nature always wins like if you
get into nature it just resets you it's
like biorhythms and everything just
clicks in
so it's about that and it's about like
i don't think it's like a brave new
world like we're scaring people
in any way i think it's just like a
relatable story of like these people go
away for a weekend with no cell phone no
wi-fi yeah and they get so paranoid they
think like the chinese have taken over
the west coast like what does that say
about
our lifestyle yeah ultimately you know
but it's also like
engaging a little bit with you know
nature and putting things away like
creating boundaries like that you know
that's that's sort of what what we
learned but it's straight up just a
comedy it's like hopefully
funny the whole way through i play a
ridiculous guy who thinks he's
crushing it by making hot sauce in his
garage so he's got he's got dan's devil
sauce and he thinks he's an entrepreneur
but really
he came out of an advertising job that
didn't pan out he was supposed to keep
keep climbing and he's basically kind of
licking his wounds a little too long
okay and then in the meantime his wife
played by eva jumps into this other
career and she's like crushing it but
she's kind of like gone a whole other
direction so now she's sort of stay at
home so it's been this reversal which
they haven't really established but also
like he needs to get his shift together
and then she needs to maybe tone it down
a little bit you know what i mean
yeah in a way and and so that's kind of
what's underneath it all is is is that
and and
and i think going into the rural
part of the story which
we filmed it during covid which was a
miracle like nothing bad happened nobody
got common but it was like a simple
story where they go to the remote
wilderness and
going to these remote places as you know
people who don't engage with
all different likes of people can
preserve a point of view on the world so
it's also about that yeah you tend to
get
more conspiracy theorists or more like
odd prejudices let's say when you get to
remote regions simply because they're
not bumping into a variety of life in a
simple way so we sort of get into that a
little bit too oh interesting yeah yeah
i mean like i said i feel like it's
hyper relevant right now because
everyone does i think have that
fear or curiosity in the back of their
brain that if i woke up and my wi-fi
didn't work tomorrow
could i get in my car and know where to
drive without a gps signal like uh all
of these like small things that make you
feel a little bit
uh
weak or inferior or like completely
incapable as like a human being in the
world
well one of our producers debbie
liebling who's an awesome producer
she won't look at her screen time usage
on her phone because she's like
constantly multitasking
she is afraid of looking at it she will
never look at her
have you done that
uh i have thought about it i have not
engaged with it because i
don't want to be that confronted with
my truth but i have friends that will
put limitations on their phone like um
you know i can all the i guess there's
things in your phone where you can
literally say i'm i have to my phone
will shut off this app after two hours
of use but they reach that period by
like noon and realize that they have to
restructure their actual limitations
because it's not actually working for
them and there's a bit it's a bit
devastating to kind of be confronted
with that
um
i'm also curious because the i'm going
right now go to your phone come on i say
i don't want to
because come on i don't wanna i don't
know you do that well but it's gonna be
awful i play scrabble go literally all
day long so a little bit with my mom
me too four hours seven months oh you do
isn't it a neat thing i stay in touch
with your mom i play over the pandemic
we started getting into playing scrabble
go with each other and i think it's very
sweet and cute i
sometimes have to let her win but uh
otherwise it's very very fun uh highly
recommended but that's gonna [ __ ] up all
of my screen time that's gonna throw
everything
come on look at it okay i haven't looked
at mine in months what's your average
four hour seven minutes on average okay
that's what it says five hours 38
minutes
which honestly isn't as bad as i thought
it would be
gorgeous
um okay amazing
it's not crazy
i ripped the bandage uh and i'll work on
that um
thank you for getting me to be
vulnerable i work on this in therapy and
it's nice to practice it in the real
world
[Music]
okay
i'm actually gonna skip ahead to the two
questions this is what we'll wrap up
with that i ask every single guest that
is on the podcast
the first question i ask is who alive or
dead would you most like to throw cold
spaghetti at
what
um
[Music]
and this is something that is
truly individualized of your intention
uh you can
have a person in mind that is your
answer for right now but this is an
answer that can constantly evolve and
change over time
i feel like i want to go between
it goes between like
galileo or
like astropythicus like a caveman who
wouldn't understand her food
like to throw a meal like that at a
caveman and have them like
eat it and understand that it's
delicious and also with galileo i feel
like
he would probably give me some
scientific explanation of how it
traveled and hit him
either way i would like to watch the
learning curve of both of those moments
okay the other question i ask every
single guest is to tell us
your worst pants [ __ ] story or like
a bathroom emergency situation however
you can only use three words or like
small phrases
to describe the event
and for example mine
is college jogging front lawn
i mean
i thought you were frozen for a second i
was like oh no not again
uh
forewarned diarrhea second grade that's
four words but
i mean it's a beautiful poem that's what
you just made
forewarned diarrhea second grade yeah it
also sounds like a weird dido song or
something
matt i appreciate so much this
conversation and thank you for being so
patient with the technical difficulties
uh before we let you go we like to give
a token of our appreciation to each
guest by giving them a personalized
horoscope that we have written for you
uh that melissa just put in the chat if
you'd like to read it aloud
who who created it
uh uh our
writer that works on the show okay
so is it
before i read it is it
just
because of the day and time or whatever
i was born or is it related to
my profession and my history as a
performer or you know what i mean it's a
bit of a combination uh we understand
that you're a libra based on your birth
date um so it's a bit of that as an
inspiration but then facilitated into a
more personalized
statement based on your life experience
thank you you got it
dear libra
scales of the stars expect venus to form
a conjunction with pluto and capricorn
this weekend
i still don't know what it means good or
bad
this is the time to come up with new
family traditions for the holidays
i like that and by new we do not mean
forcing your whole family to watch
chicago pair highlights on espn classic
penny doesn't care oh my god
how do you know i have a dog named penny
i mean it's in the stars apparently oh
my god
they're in the universe penny was on
camera for a moment she's the best and
she's bouncing around back there she's
got lots of energy yes
uh well i hope that you're a holiday
tradition we have a family tree a new
family tradition we still haven't gotten
our trees so there's plenty of time to
start traditions plenty of time um matt
where can people listen to the podcast
second in command and where can they see
unplugging potentially uh unplugging
will be coming out in the spring of next
year and like
810 cities and also on digital
uh platforms and then the second in
command podcast is on if you go to cast
media.com you can find it there or
anywhere you listen to podcasts second
in command i'm sure you can find it
amazing well thank you again so much
this was such a lovely conversation yeah
it was very delightful as well on my son
oh great and guys go check out
everything that he's up to and um if you
see anything that he posts online no
it's either from him or uh directed from
his assistant yes that is absolutely
true
and we'll see you guys next time on an
episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music